[Music]
what was what that the music did you
hear it yeah I think so
played again Sam
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I definitely heard at that time but
you didn't really notice the first time
did you that is what a good score does I
know it enhances a mood without even us
being aware of it mm-hmm
yeah and you know it basically the
emotional thing now what here on the
podium yeah anywhere else we're gonna
present the award I knew that the
nominees for Best Original Score I cry
freedom
George Fenton and Jonas guangwu for
Empire of the Sun John Williams for the
Last Emperor
ryoichi Sakamoto David Byrne and kongfu
The Witches of Eastwick John Williams
[Applause]
[Music]
for the intouchables Ennio Morricone and
the winner is the winners are ryuuichi
Sakamoto David Byrne and pong suited for
the Last Emperor
[Music]
this is a lot of fun thanks to Bernardo
Thank You Jeremy it's uh this is a lot
of fun but it's more fun doing it
thank you I want to thank myself that
Ruchi Jeremy Thomas the producer all my
friends my staff assistants thank you
very much guys yet another parameter is
Hamas decision how what Allah made
puncture or cement and other announced
you want um body thank you thank you
said you don't you thank Bernardo and
Jeremy and thank the rest of us
collaborators and thank everyone in
worshiping would have more interest in
the arts of China señor Bernardo the
legitimate